just a small tangent
you mentioned marc andreessen it sounds
like in bill joy
but staying on mark it sounds like he
had
an impact on you in that he sort of
believed in what you were doing there
can you can you talk about like what
role mark had in your life
yeah we would meet at the um the
peninsula creamery in downtown palo alto
and mark was just fresh out of you know
grad school or whatever he was doing and
he was
a big dude and he got fitter later uh he
had hair
he he would order giant milkshakes and
burgers and we would meet there and
brainstorm about what to do and it was
very direct because
we didn't have much time the the sort of
we didn't talk about it but the
implication was microsoft's coming after
us mark was saying things boldly
uh pre-ipo like netscape plus java kills
windows right this is
ambitious makeup browser programmable it
becomes the new runtime for programs
it's the meta os or it's the replacement
os um but he still
saw value in javascript yes even though
he was saying that and java was the big
name
hence the trademark license uh he saw
javascript is important
and he even thought what if we got i
told this another interview so i can say
it he thought what if we had
uh my friend kip hickman who'd been at
netscape from the beginning and who was
a
kernel hacker at sgi when i joined he
started writing
his own jvm before we consummated the
sun deal and got our hands on their code
and the java compiler java c which
arthur van hoff had written very nice
code was all written in java it was
self-hosted or so-called bootstrap
and so we could use that as soon as
kip's java vm could run
the byte code from the sun uh
jvm running the the self-hosted compiler
to emit the bike
so once we could bootstrap into kip's vm
we wouldn't need sun and
mark was like well maybe we can just you
know ditch sun
or java vm or if you're a javascript vm
we
now we need graphics so mark was
thinking far ahead because he knew
you could do things with html and images
but at some point you really want like
cinema graphics or yeah
three-dimensional like even sgi had
already started its downfall because the
first floor
vlsi team there had gone off to do 3dfx
and all these other companies that made
the graphics card on your pc right doom
was was big and quake and so you were
all playing quake i was old so i was
terrible
but why not put that graphics capability
on the web and in fact it finally
happened
uh and mozilla with firefox era with uh
vlad vokicovic
taking opengl es and reflecting it as
webgl but opengles
is the mobile version of opengl which is
a standard based on sgi gl so this whole
lineage of graphics libraries
or really graphics languages for the
what became the gpu
and mark was thinking ahead it's like we
need graphics too and i thought okay i
could try to get somebody i knew at sgi
but he's a grad student at mit
was studying under barbara liskoff he
laughed when he heard about this later
andrew myers he's at cornell a long time
i think he's a full professor
and mark said great we'll get him i'm
not sure he's going to come
we'll throw money you know stock options
we never did it
and they did the sun deal so kip nobly
put aside his own jvm and we used the
sun jvm
so that was an ambitious period and mark
was very generative because he was
pushing hard
he was ambitious and he wanted to
have netscape possibly be in control of
the ball
you